hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to Hilary
Swank you may remember her from boys
don't cry Million Dollar Baby
and my personal favorite dramatic
performance followed by that yeah I'm
finally a complete person yes it's true
the Hilary Swank certainly dies in a lot
of movies but very rare that an entire
movie dies either before you pronounce
the title let's try the next Karate
now some of you might be saying wait
what do they make another karate kid I
don't remember that well if you take
your copy of Karate Kid Part three and
simply turn it around
bingo Karate Kid 4 that's right this
film is so bad that couldn't even get
his own DVD room and be teamed up with
the other piece of shit karate tips
equal justice in a live event
so what's wrong with what a Hilary
Swank's very first movies well let's go
over a little history the first run DK
came out 1984 it started back Macchio
it's kinda fun and the guy from Happy
Days is mr. Miyagi
it's now sort of a standard story it's
about a kid who gets beat up by bullies
and over the top teacher so he works
karate from a quirky but wise karate
master his methods are strange but
effective and at the end became finally
proven by fighting against the bullies
in eternity standard for the joy one the
signal was a little different Miyagi and
Daniel go to Okinawa doumyouji can visit
his dying father and make amends with
his angry growing it wasn't as good as
the first that wasn't half bad even
though I had a small team Olmec just
continued the story
it wasn't just a cheap retread of the
original that was left for the third and
this one flat out son it was the same
story as the first once in character
think what friends the only thing that
was different was instead of one handy
over the top billing you had to but all
the business aside for Overbeck wid only
they say that Margaret I'm going to be
working full-time ones from now on
full-time for the next few weeks my
business is strictly revenge everything
is in place
who the hell talks like that nobody
calls up their secretary says oh by the
way here for my meetings I'm going to
have a diabolical plan to destroy my
arch nemesis thank you at all things
that are thin climax
what a load of shit shit class do you
think that would be the worst Karate Kid
movie right well just a mere five years
later they tried to catch him with
another karate chop to my nuts in their
latest and final sequel the next Karate
Kid well I think I've built up the
shitstorm long enough let's take a look
so it starts off with mr. Miyagi
accepting some sort of army unit
citation along with the wife of one of
his old army buddies Louisa
they catch up on old times talk about
Chinese food or something when we're
introduced to the karate brat herself to
me this was mr. Miyagi he was a friend
of your grandfather high-heeled some
respect he came all the way from Karate
Kid Part three for this I want you to
talk to him you invited him here you
talk to him where are you going
Susan my name is Julie my mother's name
was Susan she was killed in a car
accident with my father and they're both
dead every one exhibition every other
movie yes the next Ronnie can you talk I
mean wow that was just painful
how much more force could you possibly
get my name is Julie my mother's name
was Susan she was killed in a car
accident with my father and they're both
dead everybody got that so where's our
the angry trouble Julie sneak off to in
the middle of the night
love sure she's Parsons our gang or
something or some sort of criminal drug
ring or some kind of illegal underground
hiding or something else to make the
real payoff look unbelievably stupid she
breaks into her school which is ironic
because most kids trying to break out of
school and she spends her time feeding a
bird oh no really this is the height of
her troubled teen done feeding a hawk
with a damaged wing unless she's gotta
use it for cockfighting that's not very
impressive but Boston's doughy just
arrived on the scene as they try to stop
her and we go bird being I love this
scene watch
yeah shine a light on the people you
don't want to find you and then throw it
at them so that you can't see where
you're going now technically you could
argue that she's trying to distract them
away from the bird but why doesn't she
just drop it off at a set to begin with
what if she karate kid' any beyond here
makes no sense let me just stop that
these guys are about as fit as the
morbidly obese pill don't make me Ron
I'm filled with pork chops and syrup so
in a sort of strange foreign exchange
program Susan weeds Boston to go to
California while mr. Miyagi leaves
California to look after Julie makes
sense to me yeah you pick up air this
afternoon okay Julie
[Music]
gee I wonder if this is the villain yeah
yeah just because you can hold on a shot
doesn't mean you should tie morning
Julie
so she's approached by one of the bag I
know of course you can tell the bad guy
because we always wear the black shirt
and get you into little trouble or I
could pick you up tomorrow night and
take it down to the docks you've been to
the Ducks I mean really dream on hey
most girls in this school like me you're
lucky to get an invitation typical teen
love story boy meets girl boy challenges
girl to fight on docks something's not
right about that so it turns out that
psycho kid is working for the strange
sort of school security called alpha
League but most people if you compare
them to the Third Reich ready
some kid drops a candy wrapper you make
them pick it up and eat it that's both
odd and cool their coach was actually
named Colonel Dugan partakes in normal
after-school activities like punching
his students in the face taking venom
with God and just let out shopping in
the enemy's Wikus that's when you
destroy them any bad will be fired but
for the lazy convenience of the story
let's just go with it one of the
students is named Erica
could you Lee has a crush on Colonel
Dugan Komi took to the kisser next class
hey problems No
good don't forget she's mine she's mine
to beat and/or make my girlfriend Eric
five out about Julie's first degree bird
beating and Sookie tweet with her about
whether or not even going to tell anyone
if anyone finds out about angel they're
gonna take her away that what you call
an angel how do you know she's a girl we
just answered the question I'm not
getting out of this car can you tell me
what you're gonna do fine this is okay
that's all my other girlfriend so go
ahead and you like my car it's a total
deal for for two it's just a car it's
just a car does Michael Jordan just play
basketball yeah have you seen him play
baseball so that's where they formed
some sort of bond I guess mr. Miyagi and
Julie find that they don't quite get off
on the right foot
Miyagi also talk to people your teachers
bring home my homework you miss for
three weeks don't order me around I told
you this morning I know where I'm going
in my life and I don't need any math
problems to get there how about this
math problem what does one-fifth plus
your face equal duty time when you're
just a out of my life sometime you want
to do that's right tell you nothing try
to teach you something teach me okay you
you can't even speak English oh that is
mr. Miyagi you do not miss mr. Miyagi
he's on yoga he could snap his fingers
in your brain when fucking explode
there now you see it's not nice to mess
with mr. Miyagi got tired to smoke your
head you're not tired okay I'm gonna run
back into the house bounce originally
running away from go ahead do what my
grandmother does tell me I made another
mistake Julie you're so thoughtless
Julie you lost your temper again okay
then what
Julie Sam yeah you know need say nothing
you're not gonna say anything well you
learned that learn what jump into Tiger
position when cow almost hit you so she
told him that her father used to teach
her karate which is funny because mr.
Miyagi used to teach her father cut away
a minute and no bring them back was it
right that they were killed death not
fair to anyone but still we must live
our lives I used to see them so bright
in my mind clear now all I have are
these photographs look I'm running out
the fortune cookie saying can we just
cut to the sports montage I thought
maybe you could give me a few lessons
you pay me Iggy take for homework paper
payment the one cultivation start right
now
good first we elect the car it's a
handle axe oh oh here we go ah forget it
I'm not waxing anybody's car yeah but
first we lexico and we work an engine
you know what I don't think you know
anything about girls I'm going to be a
boy from now on nobody will take that
the wrong way
well it's easier so she sees past the
wax on wax off ball too deep but Miyagi
instead hired her on to be a babysitter
next door
[Music]
three dead children later julie has
learned a valuable lesson babysitting
some time good exercise for karate
student charissa when where you learn
how to break boards and stuff like that
why break boards what boards do to you
they afford was riding the car to kill
my family okay does she breaks out again
for her Oh bird beating and it turns out
there's a few friends waiting birds
cops it was a girl let's go through
what's going on we're gonna bust you for
breaking the school even though we're
technically breaking the school is about
you but Julius Keith says the tight
shirt boy cracker down no way absolutely
let's just talk
let's try to be friends Julie right is
that trash school property even though
they're high have to protect it God
these guys made no sense will you stop
throwing your flashlight it's not a damn
gas bomb so Julie gets in trouble again
and it's kicked out of school for two
weeks so mr. Miyagi decides to take this
time to take notice of month two teacher
the true ways of karate but before they
get there they have to go through a few
more stock a-holes who can start a fight
if you just need wrong
she's my don't turn them into a dance
chick come on let's just get out of here
ain't going nowhere really as much
karate is puppetry but I guess I'll
there that was great mr. Miyagi that's
great yeah you always look for a way not
to fight yeah you hate fighting and if
somehow I do it all for film and like I
guess so they get to the monastery or
whatever the hell this place is as
Miyagi tries to teach Julie or first
food make round cake land on Okinawa
that's impossible
it's my affair so she goes to eat with
the mouse when she suddenly spots a
cockroach what that's the problem with
in monastery words
nothing is ever killed
what a stupid rule oh no you didn't he
Miyagi don't live in monastery Julia but
still respect all living things now if
you'll excuse me there's a fly I had to
crush with my chopsticks so what would
be horrific except a cockroach murder
they decide to eat separately from
Julian afraid that her nykeya do hard
yet another innocent animal cockroach
killer or slack I do not know you but
it's ok because she brings the Mantis
into the monastery and I guess that
makes everything better somehow
sorry I tried to kill the cockroach look
and what do you have it
fucking I did this so the training
continued that she has taught to fight
obstacles without any dish come on mr.
Miyagi how can I block an attack if I
can't see failure use iya nervous scheme
going to use all senses your eyes can
deceive you don't trust them ok I swear
that last are worthless guitar so he
continues to show her how to defend
herself against names and catcher's mitt
until they finally decide she's ready to
leave but not before one last bit of
bullshit that they had to go through it
is demonstrations any attorney is nice
the small team and it didn't become
possible
I just shit myself because she finally
gets to go back to school and what's the
first thing she wants to do I want to
take the bun that's right eat her damn
bird mr. Miyagi suggests that maybe it's
time to let the hawk go now release mr.
Miyagi any shot maybe you be injured
believe - yes throw her into the water
and she flies but she was ready to fly
if she falls then she'll do it
so of course she flies away and just in
time soon the dance is coming up and not
only is mr. Miyagi teaching her the
latest dance moves but he also managed
to get a dress for her yeah you want you
to go then how'd you know my side
that was pretty difficult part okay
now that's a legitimate question I mean
we got out of our own belief in our
hands or something so well Julie go to
the dance with Erik Miyagi and his mom
friends go bowling Wow
saying that out loud just made me
realize how stupid that sound hey hey
don't touch this ball all right this
ball just serious money don't understand
the English look don't talk either
elective program don't breathe don't
move I don't want any distractions
okay how about every person in a Karate
Kid movie is an asshole I mean it's like
hi how you doing what do I saw something
go throw them - come on Big Boy to us
look course they beat them at bowling
and make their way home
meanwhile at the dance Julian Eric are
getting nice and friendly into
[Music]
great thanks sugan it would be alright
leave them alone McGowan what just
happened
she's real smart Annette I think you
broke your buddy's arm here at least it
was brave enough to try it try acting
like a moron
why it's just fine the business I don't
of you I mean yeah I honestly have no
idea what that one your bungee jumping
to know the dance of what I don't know
what is that none of this would have
happened if it hadn't been for me I'm
still not sure what happened
I mean come on homie with it extreme
bobbing for apples where they're doing
with a jackass done what laughs oh
there's no time to explain or miss the
movie I think there's no time to explain
and the bad guys challenge Erik - would
you like s where where else the docks
finally we get the Phoebe damn docks
they can hide up so much I didn't think
you were gonna show I'm at the bullring
McGowen right it car what is with these
people at school security not fuckin
gangland now it's payback time
okay we'll do a background check on that
guy finish him off with a lot where is a
murder is part of a job what are y'all
looking at we think I've been training
you for manslaughter of course this
looks like a job for a teenage girl in
an old Asian man
what what are you kidding me
let me fight him no you have to fight me
no like she wants to fight me - Miyagi
I'm never gonna respect myself I have to
do this no no Judy sounds right
No wow that took a lot of coaxing listen
me up you wanna fuckin know good point
Wow
Lola Judy what are you talking about
the war is not over because when battle
is lost you register caja it's not over
and Leasing you know for a guy who
doesn't like fighting he sure doesn't do
it a lot
[Music]
missiny RGGI what's your title spectrum
III and II fall away
not quite what I had in mind but okay
new yorky with blue elegy took some
money I think that's good that's if bust
tight we so I have to give this movie
some credit it's nice enough not to have
an epilogue it just sort of stops like
okay we torture you long enough you can
do now and thank God - because it turns
out the next Karate Kid was also the
last Karate Kid
they never made another movie sequel one
thing can delete Jesus because these
film simply got worse and worse and
worse but in all honesty to the film's
credit it did try online audience it did
try I'm a Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to okay one more drew
or do not there is no try
keep a little bit of it